and we're also filming Keeping Up with
the Kardashians right now so where's see
the camera crews here right there hello
over there they're back yes Keeping Up
with the Kardashians returns at this
March and the first look has given us
everything we want including Kim's a big
a baby number four revealed we have an
announcement we're having a baby you
decide to save things like maybe the
baby reveal or different things for the
show and say let's put that in the show
and then other things are for social
media it's just it they we film
everything and we try to show as much as
we can in 44 minutes once a week on a
one at horse show so we try to get in
there as much as we can that we know
that everybody will love and it's just
so good so we'll get to see Kim navigate
a growing fam number four you never know
but I think after that I mean that's
that's a lot three is a lot is three
more than you thought it would be
definitely I mean my mom kind of preps
me and it was crazy cuz when everyone
found out that I was having a third
everyone had a crazy story for you I'm
just like two was great but three-year
outnumber your exhaustion your that like
all these like nightmare stories and I'm
like why are you bothering to tell me
this she'll also be dealing with Kanye
Kanye's friends always publicly talked
about him we have different views
sometimes we have different things but
that's my husband you know plus we got
to watch khloe take on being a mama i
could be selfish and spend all the time
with me and my daughter be here I think
also motherhood just puts life into
perspective and what's important to you
but I think you just re-evaluate things
like I don't want to do that tonight and
it's okay to say no so I can spend time
with my family
Kourtney and Scott being well Kourtney
and Scott I don't want you to think I'm
giving a mixed
you barely give a regular message and
Kourtney and Kanye doing we don't even
know what
Kourtney's obsessed with Kanye family
and it swaps together stays together
together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]